dad didn't even play the intro did not
play
anyways hello whoa sorry guys alright I
saw that just start please from Missha
Keys plays I feel like you said that
yesterday too but either way what's up
guys I do not know why the intro did not
play but either way I'm Eric obviously
if you've been here before if you have
it welcome nice to meet y'all
we're gonna be doing some Destiny to
week three reset on PC
we got the inverted spire this week as
well as the first faction rally for PC
Sawalha
kind of hop into that right now
so right there you can see there's dead
orbit Iman Turkey future war cult then
kind of just quickly peruse to see what
they're selling if you guys haven't seen
it yet figure that'll give some time for
people to get in here also apparently
there's a really crazy like fast token
farm that I can show you guys to some my
clan mates on console told me about it
this morning and it is pretty broken so
you get three tokens per lost sector now
and I want to say I got about like I
don't know like eighty to eighty-five
tokens in like 10 minutes which is
pretty insane like I already have 200
tokens I'll show you guys the farm spot
here is the truth teller which is the
weapon that we would be able to purchase
assuming dead orbit finds a way to win
again highly unlikely because it's a
great nail grenade launcher there dead a
grenade launcher most people are
probably not gonna want that anyways
here's some of the stuff you can get the
armor set looks not bad I would say it
has pretty good perks if you're looking
for recovery and resilience really what
that set is and then you got the shaders
of course dead orbits fate looking
pretty good traditional kind of black
and white dead orbit style and this
one's I think the camel one yep not a
huge fan of the camo but you know dire
promise is a hand cannon that they sold
previously if you played console if you
haven't then good luck to you guys it's
a decent hand cannon it's got
triple tap then you got the eleventh
hour' sidearm I think this one's very
okay it's me
it's got rampage though you got the
shotgun gravity slingshot who really
ever crouches this though is probably
the best gun you can get from dead orbit
this time around it's the Auto rifle
guiding star I think it's like the skate
lock archetype it's got high caliber
rounds which is really good so yeah and
then moving target better target
acquisition
you got Haunted earth this is the Scout
that was sold that win dead over it won
the console faction reality the first
time it's got also has high caliber
rounds but I think it shoots relatively
slow so that's why slow Scouts are not
so great here's another scout rifle from
the vice tour based gun company
essentially a autoloading holster it
looks cool so I probably want one of
those cuz I've never gotten one and then
you got submachine gun escape velocity
with grave robber and it also has high
caliber rounds so it could be decent
yeah so that's dead orbit I'll turn in
packages later guys
we're also gonna do the nightfall today
hello
BW TV Luigi I think double-oh-seven new
here thank you for tuning in
Taytay do it every day I heard anything
regarding Xbox one expat I have not we
have one in the office and I want to say
Jake er and maybe Nick margarita also
have one there should be at their desk I
haven't heard anything about the update
that oh I totally passed future will
call or call them so sorry guys I was
reading chat hello Ari yeah dead Korea I
know about that was the guiding star
available last faction rally no it was
not JV its new the auto rifle that viced
scout rifle and that submachine gun are
new to this faction rally I haven't
checked console yet but I feel like it's
kind of bad luck
or it's gonna be bad orangey if they did
in fact as more guns because true
prophecy was in the last one it was a
decent hand cannon its I still think
better Devils is is better the number is
a great auto rifle though so if you're
looking for a good auto rifle this one's
pretty good it's on par with Orioles
gift
hey do a mission I'll do a mission soon
don't worry
Pleiades correct are also a really good
scout rifle so that's something you guys
should aim for a heart of time is the
one that was the if if future war call
have would have won this is the pulse
that would have sold the first faction
rally
it's got Firefly which makes it
interesting they got our submachine gun
a sidearm which was the needler from
beta and then a grenade launcher no one
cares about grenade launcher will go to
new monarchy real quick so that we do
not show bias even though dead orbit for
life you guys know that I don't think
they're gonna win this time around just
because the grenade launcher is just
crappy and new monarchy has a sword
gamespot are you Chinese my name is Erik
and yes I am Chinese what's up that was
septic eye if you were curious about my
race that is what I am technically
speaking I'm half Singaporean if we
wanted to get real technical Singapore
is a small little country near like
Malaysia it's kind of near Japan in that
area if you're looking on the map
alright here let's get the new monarchy
and then I will show you guys the insane
farm run on how to get coins fast Erik
rewards don't matter too much faction
people dead orbit will always win that's
from Bob Jones and twitch it's possible
you never know here but here's the sword
man they got a sword honors edge oh
sorry I didn't show the future war cult
fusion it's a decent but honors edge
this thing looks pretty cool like I'd
want to probably want this one out of
all the three that you could win new
monarchy armor for Titan is by far the
best-looking I feel like I think it's
the crack set though so sorry justice
got rifle decent I was in the first one
submachine gun I didn't really use from
the first faction rally unification
shotgun this is a new Scout that they're
selling this time around us again when I
say new it's just this is the second
time technically for those on console
but for PC obviously it's the first time
here's a side arm older sister 3 is I
think gonna be a decent hand cannon
possibly for crucible maxim 11 this this
uh sniper I think is gonna be decent for
PvP too
so there you go they're the three
factions I allied myself with dead orbit
because dead orbit for life also I
really want the Auto rifle the guiding
star I'm gonna quickly show you guys
this farm run you guys can do it if you
want to or not it's kind of it can be a
little tedious and a little boring hello
and goodbye Magic Man it can be a little
tedious or boring but it's very
efficient so if you're trying to get
coins and not have to do a lot of work
come down a winding Cove here which is
where we're flying to and let me just go
full game here so yeah what you want to
do for this farm to get about roughly I
would say 80 to 100 coins every 10 to 15
minutes possibly more would be to come
down to winding Cove I guess we'll oh I
just missed it that's unfortunate there
is a public event but they've finished
there anyways we're gonna head on in to
winding Cove here and did this loss
sector I can actually fall into it there
you go
gonna head on over yonder to the left
hopefully I make this jump I didn't
because I'm a scrub at jumping I feel
like jumping and movement in general is
easier on
Wow
not enough coffee today guys all right
here we go so I don't know if you guys
have done this last sector before but
once you get up here into the weap area
you're gonna need to kill these things
in the console faction rally those used
to give you tokens from just killing
those but now they don't so I'm gonna
kind of keep going here you don't have
to kill this stuff and cuz it's in my
way keep going farther here so there's a
boss guy that has the cash codes we need
to kill him obviously
he'll come back I'm joking he's like in
that corner
appears we need to kill one more of
those
captain is between a real cannon but and
slowing our run down
[Applause]
right because might actually die nope
it's not how to start off the stream
fill that thing oh we might die to
burning okay alright so in theory I
should have this key thing you're gonna
get three tokens for finishing you're
gonna want to jump up here and then make
your way up here and then you're gonna
go until it says winding Cove then
you're gonna wrap back around and then
you're gonna go through these doors open
this chest again get three more coins
and we're gonna rinse repeat and yeah I
mean this is pretty much it
you're gonna get roughly like I said I
think in ten minutes I farmed about 28
chests we multiply that by three it's
about 84 if my math is correct
so 84 in ten minutes
times that by six you're looking at like
what someone do the math for me 84 times
6 or just do 80 times 6 I guess is like
what PI 40 right no 4 anyways there you
go this is pretty much the farm run if
you want to do that go for it remember
you can only turn in 30 packages worth
which is 600 tokens unless you want to
make sure that your faction wins you
don't really need to farm past 30
engrams unless there's a weird bug like
the first action Valley on console which
allowed future war cult to go past 30
weird
yeah hope you enjoyed this little farm
tutorial since I ran this way anyways
I'm gonna grab one more and we're gonna
wrap it up so good luck and happy
farming Oh beans all right let's do the
nightfall yeah
so they buffed the nightfall a little
bit in that um you get 15 coins per now
I wonder if Jared wants to do the
nightfall I need here I am willing to
take two people in chat through the
nightfall ideally I'd like you to
hopefully be over 260 light if not 270
if you guys are available that'd be
awesome and you can send me your battle
tag and I'll add you that way
that's legit exploit Wow yeah it's a
pretty broken yeah real tough it'll keep
working there's a bunch of other people
doing this you'll see them sometimes in
here if you're just having an instance
with them but yeah
farm tutorial more like exploit well you
know it's in the game you can do what
you want with it
you view it however you want this has
been this the funny thing is this kind
of strategy has existed since destiny
one when we when you used to have to
farm planetary materials you used to
just be able to instance out of like one
zone and then run back or sparrow back
to the other zone and then reform that
planetary material so it's not something
that's totally uncommon in destiny
unfortunately but you don't have to do
this obviously you can also just farm by
doing like heroic public events it got
nerfed though it used to give you eight
per heroic now it only goes five but
it's still pretty fast so why choose the
faction with the worst weapon well I
like dead orbit and - I want the guiding
star Auto rifle I just want to mess
around with that I actually made most of
my characters and the stuff I care about
is mainly on console I just have one PC
character so that you know I could play
with some of y'all on the community and
also because it's like kind of the new
stuff it was fun reforming and whatnot
so there's clearly someone else doing it
Allen hustle saying I'll run it with you
cool I'm putting on PC right now z-bo
yep so Dillon DK is saying dead orbit
has an Opie Auto rifle you can get from
the tokens yeah that's pretty much why
I'm trying I don't know if if how good
it is because I don't have it yet but I
definitely want to try it out someone
saying this glitch is already fixed I
doubt that's the case because I'm
literally doing it right now so I'm
pretty sure it's not fixed if you want
to try it cool if you don't that's
totally up to you guys I just wanted to
show you guys that that is a possibility
there's not really a reason to go
unlimited coins unless like I said you
really want to make sure your faction
wins Allen I'm gonna need your battle
battlenet tag here
we're just gonna keep doing this I guess
for the time being it yeah it's it's
it's not fixed and I mean I was doing
this earlier and then relog here in the
stream room so it definitely hasn't been
fixed yet
I mean it could be one of the it could
just be a good Samaritan trying to you
know stop people from doing it which is
fine Allen hustle I know there you go
all right cool let me go full camera
real quick so I don't necessarily expose
the screen here and then I will add you
Alan we still need one more this week is
momentum and time warp rings so let's
make sure that we don't just jump into
the rings until we kill everything that
would be the best bet Exodus 30 add a
friend Alan I just sent you a request
it's coming from Katie a why dylan
saying a case why did you know that this
exploit you're actively doing right now
is fixed totally makes sense right now I
don't yeah I mean the only way that that
would ever be true is if I was still in
the game and they haven't actually like
reset or put a patch through and I'm
still able to do it because I'm logged
in and then other people logging in
aren't able to do it but I'm pretty sure
they still haven't fixed it so yeah I'm
gonna hit up someone
one person
Allen I added you so just join when you
have a second I'm gonna ask this other
guy if he wants to join there's social
tools are a little bit better go prove
that it's still working for those that
don't think that it's still working
it's kind of like Luke came 2.0 but not
not as good obviously uh because I
haven't gotten a purple out of this
chest yet from doing this I've only
gotten the three coins which is fine I
mean you're pretty you're pretty much
doing it for the the token so that you
can quickly get your packages I think if
you do this really quickly like if you
pop pop on tomayto or something you're
probably gonna be able to get you know I
want to say like you might be able to
get your six hundred coins thirty
packages in like an hour if you're
really fast and efficient I'm pretty bad
at jumping so psycho psycho go psycho
send me your battle tag and unless this
guy responded let me double check this
guy didn't wanna be getting a response
like psycho we will get you in but I'm
not the best that's alright that's not
the end of the world oh why not gameplay
sorry I was adding people to to play
with the nightfall
all right that guy's farming tokens he's
probably worried the exploit or whatever
is not gonna work anymore so psycho if
you can give me your give me your
battlenet tag I'll get you in here in a
second
so here's gameplay sorry it would just
go do this stuff outside instead of
continuing to do that farm
really Wiley what we're getting coins
it's because we were nearby people
turning into the little Supply Drop
Holdings
all right actually this is showing me
that's cool
stealth track
for the diet anyways where do I put my
attack you're gonna need to put it into
this chat sorry I was looking kind of
looking away their storm Phoenix if
things happen or drop out I'll get you
in or maybe I'll just do it twice and
for the folks here do you think fire
team Italian effects this I don't think
it'll affected if it does affect it at
all it'll be the drops not the coins I
have the fire team with a lien on
sometimes I don't even feel like it does
as much as I like you would think it
would but it doesn't hurt to have it if
you don't want to spend your price on
whoa a lot of people putting in the tags
here psycho because you were first to
ask for after bloody hear-- I need you
to put your tag in otherwise
600 tokens no full armor set that really
sucks John the that happened to me on
console when I was on my warlock I
didn't get the Tessa piece it does feel
pretty bad when you don't get a full set
in 30 engrams especially knowing that
this is gonna be the last faction rally
with this armor set if you didn't get
the time mark you're probably not
getting this this version
just like nobody's singing yet I do see
you Christopher sorry I don't know what
you asked I'm trying to like do my best
to play and we chat so apologies if we
don't get you something you might have
sent sooner why does this area look new
it's not necessarily new I was just
I'd expected this week is actually a
meses and not heed easy but we're here
so you still get five tokens for doing
this the psycho put his thing in yet if
not it's gonna be storm Phoenix storm
Phoenix if you want to put in here your
tag will pick you up because uh I don't
know where psycho is tagging unless I
missed it in which case I just profusely
apologize Oh psycho did it okay let me
take a look then let's find a spot where
hopefully won't i well i alt-tab real
quick no hold on we go to full camera
real quick and then all tab oh there you
go sorry psycho thank you appreciate it
okay yeah I'm looking at two different
monitors and I was like oh just alt-tab
and like
alright psycho I'm sending you the
request right now just join on me and
Exodus I'll call them Exodus
we need to shoot the Thresher Exodus has
departed not sure why start in a second
buddy
hopefully going back because if not
we're gonna have to storm Phoenix I
might need to add you if he doesn't come
back
so hold sit tight there jester 84 X we
didn't make a plan you can join it
potentially if there's still spots
there's a 100 cap on
like 500 it's playing the chess all
right we got psych go yeah so there's
the five tokens for finish line to her I
need Exodus to rejoin or I need storm
Phoenix to join a key spot is actively
working on Xbox one thanks Dylan for
confirming that director why not make
that go away that's
Oh is 254 that's so low it's real risky
uh-oh our Phoenix I don't know if you're
still there up exodus tree Jordan okay
so that's fine for the two guys that are
in here psycho and Exodus hopefully you
guys can hear me in the stream I know
that there's going to be a delay but
definitely I can hear them but I'm gonna
meet you guys
because this is gang recorded basically
don't jump through the Rings till we've
killed everything hopefully they hear
that here we go yeah funny oh the
Pleiades corrector if I'm remembering
correctly is a very good scout rifle if
you can get your hands on that that's
great
the only other scout that I think is
actually better if you can get it from
the weapon sis weaponsmith is the Minang
honest sr4 it's got pretty it's got um
explosive rounds so it's kind of like
midnight except it's elemental weapon
really like the vilaça in Auto if you
guys ever get this don't blow it up
Orioles gift obviously very good too
merciless is pretty solid I have a sins
of the past which is also very good for
clearing stuff out all right
a storm I'll get you next run we can
just do another run after this and we'll
pick up a third if you if you have the
patience for it appreciate you guys
obviously wanting to join and get in
play warframe yeah maybe do that
remember two guys running around is how
you're gonna get your health back so be
mindful of that we have 12 minutes but
there's like three sets of clocks and
whatnot
so momentum is what gives you your
health back and that's been moving
around
I'll do my best to keep my eye on chat
but uh also just playing the game how
long did it take you to get to 289 I'm
sitting at 275 currently it took me a
week to get the 289 could be higher if I
turned in my miter but yeah part of it
that helps a lot is the fact that I have
a clan obviously plans give you like
anywhere from two to four well depending
on what you're able to achieve in your
clan multiple engrams for the week that
are powerful gear so that you know
obviously helped quite a bit I was able
to get a nightfall Engram a crucible
Engram and a clan Engram which gave me
the sins of the past rocket launcher and
I got that sorry I take that back it
took me two weeks to get the tune 889 I
apologize it was like I got the 270 ish
in the first week forgot that this is
what week three week two I got to like
289 and then now I'm doing all my
milestone stuff I didn't do the raid
last week but yeah much early and then
people okay I apologize Christopher I
didn't see that I'll get you in storm
Phoenix in the next run if you have the
patience to wait like I said normally we
have two people on stream but a lot of
busy times happening here at the game
slot office so just solo it solo stream
in this one so do my best to look at in
as well apologies for not seeing that
message earlier but appreciate your
patience damn it
what is your clan level we're ranked six
but that's because we started on console
she'd probably just picked me up if you
can okay
I didn't realize that was a Gatling gun
guy I wasn't really I do any soul look
fine thanks
we'll be fine I think I hope we'll see
not a great start but uh it's not
necessarily the end of the world I don't
think just fine
we wish I had Ark
that terrible grenade on my part all
right so the first set of rings is gonna
be in this next room guys let's make
sure we like I like I said try to stay
up top like two of us one of us can go
down but we want to try to jump through
the wool rings as best as possible
how do you do damage in PvP with a nice
talker super it's tough it's not a
one-shot kill anymore you're going to
just have to tether and then shoot them
and hope that the chain explosions
killed more people nice darker I
probably needs to revamp and I'm
guessing in season two in December
they'll get their revamp so don't jump
through that ring if possible otherwise
I'm gonna have to suicide and jump
Piper's
I still wish they had heroic strike
playlist yeah a lot of people kind of
miss that and they even had it in d1
where like they had modifiers like a
mini nightfall it was a fun thing for
people to do but yeah that is
unfortunately but who knows maybe it'll
come back
you guys stay here a fail-safe you're
all cozy your data for any advice on an
energy
okay I got rocked you think there'd be
less collision there but I guess not
yeah probably don't survive me it's not
worth it
but we do need to kill this stuff and
start jumping
I miss touring farms like the best
you guys stay up there
oh yeah that's right we don't gain life
back okay guys guys up top I know
there's delay but when you guys have a
second jump through that ring try to
jump through that ring together and then
jump to subsequent rings okay no no
don't do that ring yeah
psycho shoot jump to that ring back up
there now I'm gonna go die hopefully it
responds me up top if it doesn't then
we're in real bad shape what faction am
i I'm dead orbit cool Christopher just
remind me Allah ping you again in you
know in a bit once I hopefully get
through this one wrap yeah we're screwed
I'm gonna have to start over guys yeah
it's that or we skip these rings but I
don't think we can skip these rings yes
I stayed up okay we're just gonna do it
again because we can't get back up there
and we lost quite a bit of time so we're
just gonna have to do it again that's
how it goes sometimes it's just how it
goes if you've never seen it before yeah
we're definitely starting over we lost a
lot of time and we needed those rings
those rings are probably like three to
four minutes depending on how many we
jump through the second set of rings by
three to four and then the last sets
kind of sketchy because in a perfect
world you want someone to just run
through yeah unfortunately John D I am
not on Xbox I'm currently playing on PC
but I appreciate
estelle yeah no worries about that
psycho I know there's a doy kind of was
like trying to hopefully say it soon
enough but it was definitely not soon
enough so it's all good here we go
but at least I'm proud of you guys for
listening and not jumping through the
ring until it was time to jump through
the ring so there was that some people
just kind of jumped through right away
and then you're kind of hosed that's
alright good tactic for the first time
this time I have voice did you get rid
of this stuff and forget this Scout is
having using a lob I'm using the locket
in a lot also remember guys to get your
life back you're gonna have to run
around I gotta remember that to you
actually
we're a loopy to get life back on
casting bear kid crap we don't have any
have our goodnight I guess
oh look look it's a mixed milk waterfall
can we stop him yeah this is the more of
the kind of guy that I would expect to
be up there not almost like someone was
doing for skis and we got stuck in there
what other modifiers for this nightfall
Eddy game vlog boy what's up man I see
you senpai cz what are the modifiers it
is inert or the momentum momentum for
healing and then time warp rings so you
got to jump do the Rings to get more
time
so psycho if you can hear me now I would
just chill and say you stay up top and
then once you see that everything is
dead once you see that everything is
dead then you can jump through that
first ring and we'll see from
are you serious come on hot garlic
all right psycho I'm going down you stay
up here I got to trigger these things to
spawn oh I think
alright psycho go for it you guys can
jump through the ring I know there's
delay so good luck try to get through as
many rings as you can you guys gonna
both jump through should count for both
of you guys
there you go
you've jumping through the Rings guys
come through all of them as many as you
guys can
nice work
Exodus we're just gonna have to go
forward and hopefully that just respawn
off of it all right rings do stabled but
we're good we got 11 minutes roughly so
it's pretty good
sico you're gonna be delayed on hearing
this but you can just run past all this
stuff there's run by everything psycho
I believe in you
all right don't jump through these
second set of rings till we kill
everything - I think at least I'll be
able to hear that 120 that momentum
counts Pharaoh
and of course the drills have armed with
the drills when the shooting stops
hello what also helps technically would
be a warlock with healing wrists I
killed that time
like that tank grenade kill the other
stuff
whatever gun is being shot time
crazy like lien here
all right it's like oh if you have a
super in there
alright hey stucks come with me guys if
you want to live you guys go left I'm
gonna go right
three two one we're gonna jump jump you
guys can jump dude you are both
depressing and unhelpful
now we're doing good we're doing good or
well I guess would be that's more
poverty
okay you're gone go go gadget hack
right that thing will activate itself
I'd do it but this channel doesn't have
arms I bad and I compete
that's gonna spawn be careful
those tanks laden in the next area
oh I did not see that canister well
double our cross grenade is really good
oh yeah yeah
oh yeah arc starter that yep I like it
good stuff good flood revive clutch
super
laughing days we could probably just go
but alright let's go boys let's go just
walk
apparently the trick to this is to walk
on it because if you run you're just
gonna end up eating crap okay that's
good and hopefully he makes it to all
right cool
should I get this or cod World War two
that totally depends if you've played a
lot of cod then you know all good Cod
might be the game for you if you want
something new a space sci-fi shooter
that's got a good team co-op stuff that
has stuff you can do every week I would
take at this but yeah it totally depends
on what you're looking at trying to play
here I don't know if you guys can hear
me but we're gonna kind of like Yolo the
last area I'm gonna hopefully try to
make the whole run and you guys are
gonna try to get as many rings as
possible I know that you haven't heard
that yet because it's delay but
hopefully that
normally you wouldn't have to clear this
out but because I don't have a mic for
these gentlemen anyone else see that I
just got smacked by the dude riding four
phalanx right into the wall that was a
pro spat
go-go gadget all right you guys get the
Rings I'm gonna try to pull us forward
all right
sound good sounds good all right here we
go
actually I'm gonna help jump through the
first ring then hopefully live here we
go good luck everybody
off to a great start
I'm partially being sarcastic
and we got another extra ring or two all
right we got ten minutes I feel pretty
good about that all right here we go
don't worry psycho you're getting it
pulled here with us here in a second
should be good
good job my legs
all right senior boss is my spawn here
we won't be able to get through the ring
possibly
might be tough
get you up in the second Exodus
of course itself word
to push them to the next phase disappear
become immune
Haizi me
hi you're the bestest Greek hunter
that's really nice of you say man I've
died like three times but thank you
you guys are probably gonna want to jump
on these RAM things because he's gonna
do that
it's switching guns
yeah I got snakes and then burnt they
probably won't do another action rally
until the till the next season or DLC
don't die for it Exodus it's not worth
it oh my god I can't believe you got
that off CREP
oh sweet baby Jesus we need to push him
to next phase
day
I might die for it but he's gonna die
good job y'all stressful but we did it
all right I gotta get um was it Phoenix
and Christopher good job y'all
that was good those real good you guys
put me in a backpack oh I did he punted
me though I missed I'm the the shoulder
charge slam there cool
thank you to Exodus in psycho thank you
guys for joining in on this week's fun
maybe get you in next week
get your scout rifle at 305 uh I could
try how do you get two three or five
with a scout rifle one here at 297 I
would wait and do your might uh till the
end yeah that would be definitely the
way all right gonna go quickly the
camera here so I can get Christopher and
Phoenix
I got a scroll back up to see if Eric
got a thousand tokens at no I don't like
300 or something like that hunters at
the moment are weak yeah they're not so
great unfortunately gunslingers okay but
out of the three classes they're
probably the weakest of the three not
great in PvE not great in PvP
that was their store in Phoenix
[Music]
Kristopher here in a second
all right Christopher and storm Phoenix
I just sent you guys friend requests you
guys can join me when you guys hopefully
get those first youtuber ever played
with cool thanks for coming on the run
and glad we were able to do it that
excuse me that second time we just
needed what to know what to do obviously
and obviously it's harder that I don't
have headset to tell you guys what to do
so apologies for that
I'll think about how to potentially deal
with that in the future so yeah sorry I
can't join got to leave soon no worries
that was from Christopher I think so
we'll see a store phoenix joins if he
does awesome and we'll keep going if for
some reason he doesn't get in all good
we can always just call it a day or
crucible or something so this week's
flashpoint was on necess happen to
finish that already oh there you go
there is okay so rude dog is Christopher
I believe and then storm Phoenix was the
one that can't joint okay so we got an
open spot if you guys are looking to do
the nightfall
with me and Christopher from YouTube I
got an open spot what I need you to do
is send me your battlenet tag so I can
add you and then we will proceed from
there as mentioned to some of the guys
earlier you just want to make sure you
not to jump through the time rings until
you know later on but hopefully they
were watching then they have a general
gist what we did but I have a good
feeling that Christopher must know what
he's doing because he has the raid
emblem which means he's finished the
raid which I have yet to do on PC also
challenge there's a new challenge out
this week I forget which one it is
I didn't actually look it up so
do we have one more that wants to do the
nightfall with us if not I can try to
find someone on my list
probably this guy
but yeah thanks everybody for tuning in
appreciate it on affection rally day /
weekly reset should be should be good
I'm a 298 warlock if he need help yeah
sure if you want to join if you want to
send me your deets details there I am
Duke we will get into this nightfall and
finish it up and probably call it a good
solid stream so yeah as mentioned you
get 15 tokens for your faction from
doing the nightfall so that's pretty
cool
I still have the medallion on I do I
think no I don't guess it ran out should
unfortunate but yeah JV says nice run
guys it's pretty good run I died quite a
bit but you know sometimes that's what
it takes I guess I try to not die as
much this one that's why you have a fire
team right so that when one Falls
another can be picked back up so just
waiting on could do he probably has a
little bit of a delay here and hearing
me I'm sure once he he gets a little
message for me he'll sit down over his
battle tag and we couldn't get going
mind if we go to the tyro quick no not
at all we can do that while we're
waiting for our last player he didn't
sign up for a faction yet hope you
picked the right faction Christopher for
me dead over it for life but I can also
understand some of the shaders I think
new monarchy shader looks really good to
be honest and then if you want weapons
it's hard to say this time around
what's up half moon warrior with an A
instead of a No
[Music]
trying to understand what John Dee was
sending in a YouTube chat but uh
something about rating or rated
oh we got some brightening grams we
could turn those in also Bob Joe to tell
me that I should probably clear some of
this stuff out lest I lose loot lot of
281 stuff though take you gloves nothing
is really Oh 282 gloves help a little
bit FWC auto-rifle hands down best gun
they have yeah
the scouts pretty good to you though
John Dee I am NOT gonna lose stuff to a
full postmaster
only Bob is worried for me what can I do
for omen Forbes asking really bad at PvP
any tips I would say try to play slow
learn the maps don't rush out too much
into the fray unless you really want to
and find weapons that's yes is this they
finally get the fast spawning Sparrow I
hope so
I sent my beat tag where did you send
your battle tag to could do I need your
battle tag not gonna have put in mine
necessarily into the chat unfortunately
our inventory is dollars
aegeon out welcome Guardian Ike here's
what she saw a prospector and sky
burners oh I do now I have a speed fast
or a fast spawn Sparrow now Bob on PC
where did you send your battle tag -
kaduche I don't seize it
I currently have a 305 Titan show you
get my damn multi-tool
yeah I mean if you haven't gone Mitel
yet you should it's good for PvP I post
it in chat I don't see it if you sent
your battle tag and chat I don't see it
so apologies for that I'm guessing you
use ante up d john d
no worries Christopher I'm still waiting
for kadooks oh he sent it to me via
private chat a way for me to see that I
see it I see it I totally see it I got
it could do no worries
real quick let me alt tab so you guys I
need to see the desktop I will send you
a invite shortly once I type out your
Coolio
I request Santa Co Dube and go back to
this
the other thing I like from the from the
raid mainly is the shader I just want to
shade her from the raid I guess you
could get three shaders from just doing
castellum though Christopher tell me
when you're good so that I don't leave
before we kind of get going good you can
join me when you are ready thank you or
I'll call you the legend alpha blue fire
god unfortunately not running the raid
on stream probably won't be for a while
just because we normally stream here I
can spot for about an hour to hour and a
half every day at 11 a.m. and so it's a
little bit more difficult to do a raid
on a stream because it obviously takes
you know I don't know it can take
anywhere from three to like I don't know
six hours depending on you know how fast
people adapt and learn the mechanics I
mean I know how to do everything so I
could technically tell everyone what to
do but obviously there still is
execution that needs to be done so yeah
sorry about that yeah you pronounce my
name right - thanks no one knows who the
nightbrothers are from the taken King
ready when you are all right here we go
last night fall last run thing of the
day on the stream let's get it done so
forked oogh and Christopher obviously I
don't know if you've done this one
before but it's the Rings the time ring
to get more time so if you watched what
we did in the last run previously we
want to kill everything then trigger the
Rings in the first set of rings we want
to try to keep someone up top so that
they can jump through ideally two people
because you could technically have more
than one person jump through a ring and
still gain time from it so you'd get
like a minute if you guys are both up
there I'll jump down and kind of trigger
the next phase there
I'm saying that now because there's
delay and I don't want you guys to have
to deal with that in the moment yeah so
nightfall number two kind of wish I had
another character right now if I could
just use yeah I think merciless is fine
I tend to miss with rockets so it's
probably safer bet to stay merciless
all right come on game you can do it
uh sorry I missed the message but hi
John Hayabusa that was in a gang spa
chat thanks for tuning in
ooh hot air we'll try again oh man
Duke has uh got that hot seven and no in
trials congrats to you that trials came
back last week we got some heavy hitters
in this knife hole
got a someone that's beaten the raid
Christopher and you got Duke hello I
beat almost all side and main emissions
I'm guessing I'm still stuck on the
button right yeah Leviathan like the
raid is always gonna be kind of tough
especially if you don't have a group of
six people that regularly do it you need
the team to all be able to carry their
own weight sometimes you can kind of
help back pack some people a little bit
by kind of having them do different
tasks but ultimately you still need to
execute and be coordinated so yeah just
keep trying it's not gonna be easy
sadly you know he says Wallace was easy
lol it depends I don't know on console
it was like kind of uh kind of tough
because I played with a stack team of
three Katie's okay well that'll do it
nice little stack team I was playing
with teammates friends of mine who are
more in the like 121.5 Katie
yeah don't forget guys momentum to get
your life back and time rings rings to
get time back oh look at this guy
he's gonna sparrow up and yeah yeah
you're too far back there buddy that's
what you get for trying to swag man
can you swat I've never done the raid
but I just got the raid rocket launcher
because of my clan mates did it yeah I
raid rocket raid rockets really good by
the way the only rocket I would say is
like as good or better in certain
situations is curtaincall which you can
get from nightfall or the vanguard
strikes if you get that definitely don't
dismantle it it's I think it's got
better single target dps than this into
the past but bullets are very good and
if you're looking for something like
that that does the same thing which is
cluster bombs on your rocket launcher
the next closest blue is a rocket
launcher called cupbearer which is also
pretty solid if you don't have sins of
the pass or curtain call right here
mighta amita
it's all the knee Xbox 1x my friends
have it early says alpha blue fire god
that's cool
we did a Gears of War graphics
comparison if you're curious between
what it looks like between a PC Xbox one
and Xbox normal it actually looks pretty
good on the 1x I'd have to say I
personally just there's still not enough
there's still not a game that is just
like on an Xbox that has like really
made me go like I want to play on xbox
one it's like even a game like anthem
which looks pretty good and looks like a
game I want to play isn't technically
Xbox one for Mike yeah Xbox exclusive so
I think that you might have like content
maybe that would be compelling
you guys stay up here I'm gonna go down
there as mentioned on an energy shield
and I keep overthrowing that your name
like strong army
I have to run for it
all right they jump
erekt a week on gamespot again McCready
likes that yeah I'm generally on
everything now or most things that was
really silly I mean I tried to flick the
mouse to a shoulder charge back the
other way but I lost my shoulder charge
and therefore I died but these guys did
such a great job of getting the rings
that we're at max time anyways so we are
good I have no idea where Christopher
that what's the first game system you
ever had an NES that more or less shows
my age probably
I've died once which is 2 less than last
run pink bed at three times last hour
four times when died four times
oh yeah it's in sports Barrow best
Sparrow I don't even care that it's not
a 160 sweets Barrow
Sharyl ketchup kind of hard to go back
for now
and the only way to reach it is down
past those giant pointy drill bits I
lucked out and got a 160 fast ones three
oh yeah that is the dream okay I guess
they're waiting for me to jump through
not over
mantle mantle
we are good we have 14 minutes is kind
of ridiculous
I do it but bail made the last one I
can't get you Christopher
all the way back
it's all up to me huh
good door hitting grenade I know right
pretty good how does pretty solid
Oh Thank You cabal spotting ball don't
go down you don't need to be down there
to progress
it's fine we can we just do it we're
good so you're saying you can just all
rap oh okay I thought you ran through
that we're saying that you could
technically suicide there and then just
get progressed to the next like this
area
give me a PC key please I don't have
enough money to buy I'm sorry panet or
if we ever do a giveaway stream that I
will definitely
same guy same results
I didn't know that was going to happen
phalanx is hate me
yeah I guess you could argue we don't
need
that not work are you [ __ ] me
okay ones being friendly who he lives
oh he's dead
oh we all did yeah
we don't
yeah we're good don't worry I could do
we are good
we got so much time to do 11 minutes is
like an eternity for this boss
oh come on don't don't do it now as I'm
here
keep that primary ammo
switching guns
I
all right we did a good job guys we got
Hadoop and Christopher it was seven
minutes 36 seconds left what's up twist
games used it to use a risk runner here
with the ark stuff some remain I don't
actually think I have a risk runner on
PC so probably couldn't have done that
even if I wanted to but yeah thank you
guys all for tuning in and thank you to
all the folks that were able to hop in
and play with us sorry that I wasn't
talking there during the fight they're
just trying to kind of kill kills the
boss but I really appreciate it
faction rally week hopefully you guys
picked dead orbit I think that's the
best orbit the best faction personally
but you know if not picked the affection
that you guys um want to do and I want
to be you want our key future war cult
whatever that is hope that you guys win
hope not really because I hope dead
orbit wins and everyone gets a grenade
launcher we I hope actually that's
probably the worst case scenario but
until next week we'll be back again next
Tuesday with destiny tomorrow we have
the lobby our weekly video game talk
show where we talk about reviews biggest
news our impressions on some of the big
games coming out sometimes we get to
play some of these games early tomorrow
as well I believe battlefront beta or a
sorry no battlefront to early access
starts tomorrow I believe so
we'll also be probably streaming that at
some point either earlier before the
lobby or after we haven't decided that
yet and then Thursday I haven't quite
decided what we're gonna do Thursday it
could be need for speed
payback maybe we'll play neo complete
edition now that's on PC and Friday Doom
is finally on switch hell is on switch
so we'll be playing doom on switch on
Friday so come back if you guys are
interested in that and until next time
guys I hope this outro plays but I have
a feeling that since my
intro didn't play it might not play
we'll see good bye guys thanks everyone
oh wow played
[Music]